you
so regular chess and the additional rule
the main row first player to land three
checks they do not have to be
consecutive and you win here we go
30 minutes of one minute three check
here we go any sex Bishop b4
so far I think I'm doing all right out
of the opening easy to get killed
playing his black let's take him out and
make sure the bishop doesn't hurt me
it's ready to take care I think the
worst is past let's do that a little
scary King is on an open diagonal I
could do this I'm threatening rook takes
rook whit's check now they can't go here
so easily let's try that and we're just
gonna double up that's all I want to do
actually let's try that now it's my king
safe here no no like I should I should
have captured in a different way hmm not
sure what to do
rook here yeah after
filmmaking who would have thought um oh
they already have one check with the
night
Oh yikes
oh boy that night is scary I won that I
was I was on the night twice I got one
check I
I got it I got it I'm winning that's two
and that's three John Madden
fast
you form
alright let's take the night out
oh my goat I'm so bad is the opponent
mmm okay let's let's push him away I
wanna stand this diagonal
let's get castled this is excellent this
often happens that move on the other
hands yeah you know I don't want to open
up the F file so now this Knight is
there to stay for a bit what I was going
to say is that this Bishop often has a
problem getting activated they seem to
be doing a good job of maybe getting him
activated this is scary I flush this
night away once again opening up a
diagonal towards my king is that Knight
trapped the knight is trapped I have to
take here
on the Queen I have a knight Knights are
usually much better
than the bishops and three Chuck come on
on here hitting them with a fork now
this is winning
banking some material I'll take the rook
only after one of them has moved that
way they waste a little bit of time I'll
just safeguard my king in the meantime
now I'll take I'll be very careful
yeah we just push push keep on pushing
keep on pushing they're down on time
okay whew
few players with the few games in there
already the virtual a boy for one
five-day viateur YouTube okay day
viateur YouTube assuming that's YouTube
okay III ready to win ah it must be a
little bit new to this variant
is basically a forced win now a bishop
check it's game over two active bishops
you can basically and be assured of at
least one check and I got at least one
check in there with the bishops both
being active
what's up Fineman Dirac in the chat
Mikael
is next let's see
move your deep on okay let's try this
cavemen I'm actually threatening this
move
Queen to one of these to leave is
necessary if this I could do this move
I'm going to do this
Zach you can't block the king s to go to
the light square you know who wants to
enter I believe this guy castle f5 so if
night here this is killing I just won
no he has to go here but then there's
this this is a forced win
you know there's just too much traffic I
only need one more check and that's it
determine to twelves still plenty of
time
56 in here let's see who we got next
okay let's go with EE for close to
winning
it's dangerous to to reply 'if I've in
response to e4 and this one's over
that's three don't blink
I I lost in four moves in the last
bullet shield tournament I learned this
little four move killer I resigned after
four moves it's this quick kill idea
that I was now familiar with okay we
gotta stop them let's get the night out
so I could give the bishop a kick
without Bishop b5 check Oh same old
story it's definitely worth that
investment and now we just get the
knight out of the way cuz my queen wants
to play Knight takes F to Queen here I
don't need one more check and it's gonna
be a win it's tough to avoid a knight
check King there here's the third and
final back determine its 22 John man I
believe just finished I think he moved
up a spot there I don't see him in a
game one of the top john madden again
okay
what's that move about let's go here
hmm let's get my night out
threatening this threaten you take the
night and take the pawn let's try this
move
night here I think I have to castle now
okay let's take okay let's take take
upon
see anything wrong with the Queen's are
off neither side with the check how do I
get castled I have to do this and then
this if it's okay oh I should should
a little bit sooner oh no this is the
right time for forget to take the bishop
with check this might be the better move
you
let's see how they give a check okay
that's the beginning of something scary
I think I could do that
I have rook lifts
yikes about where my time where is my
time eight seconds I had the night I had
the night uh-huh
you
I couldn't breathe
my opponents down that time that oh man
he had me in the think tank er oh man
give me white next time against John
Madden it's too difficult playing black
especially one minute
in okay white we could breathe a little
bit
playing with white no fanciness on f2 I
want to stay here and I think I'm gonna
go just go here castle I should have
done this
is winning
tonight move and this is killing one to
hear no matter what
and then queen h7 next back to
tournament skippity thank you for
subscribing skippity
all right less than 19 to go
62 in here it's probably going to stay
right there
something close gar Tiger next up
he's six is the way to go hi dear about
F to this structure negates the king
bishop the king bishops are the most
deadly oh here we go this is a threat
this is a serious threat because if
Knight takes Knight then I have one too
I only need two more checks and I have a
check threat like this I think he has to
go here no but then I take like this and
if he goes here I have that the Knights
are tough to avoid checks are tricky to
be on the lookout for that move okay
there's a second check the King has to
go to a dark square you think go to a
dark square and stay off the same color
as the knight 32 2016 less than 1800
beefy guy this is a strong guy he's
gonna throw their theory at me and
everything he knows all the tricks I
think we've played many one-minute games
five
it's running like this see where that
bishop goes I think I should still be
good because of this bishop no he's
going to try to solve that problem
hmm can I work with an open file yeah
thread is this
step up
I took oh my god I took so much time on
that move
yeah I took way too much time on em of
bishop here if they get on the open file
well they miss that
get my king safe now here now I think
I'm winning I get to take this pawn
and enter back rank issues and they
resigned I had to be careful of this
deny if I was going to do that
whoo I really went into the think tank
on that one middle game position a very
tough player that that record that we
had I think that's all now that's not
quite true we played a couple of regular
games and the other extreme the other
day but almost all our three check games
between us
in this one
it's council let's crack it open
I wanna get here
got one check close to a second maybe
should have captured the night see if I
could get him to move
Oh big trouble now may next with the
night or the Queen I got two checks to
Kings third and final already
just okay John Madden this time with
white efore best buy test in three check
let's go here first I don't want to take
him just yeah I know there's no rush
I got him controlled let's go here and
this is the reason why cuz I want to be
able to return if the knight moves
there's a problem
okay I'm winning upon he's still having
a tough day pawn push I have checks
clean they're all right I'll take rook
takes yeah
let's go here
they should push the pond
and the rook is so active I guess we're
gonna try this and go I want to go here
Bishop is so strong all right yeah the
rook is going to get active
I had get active rook I guess we're
gonna have an opposite color with three
check game oh they're gonna get a phone
they're gonna get all my pawns oh boy
getting all my pawns
this isn't fun I'm in trouble
you
run
you
seven seconds
you
oh he finally got a third check Oh what
did he have he had like point zero one
for something oh man oh my pawns ended
up on light squares and I was just
saying I want to get white against him
it's easier to play with white why
wasn't i winning with white
I got to go fishing pool now that's what
happens when I lose like that I just go
fishing and stuff just go for h2 that's
all come on rook play I could have
captured the night oh man I would have
been so happy if I
if I would have won the two queens and I
had a king there that's made on the spot
didn't need a third check to was enough
John bad good game in I see you in the
chat
Jiji he could definitely catch up to
he's got fire and we got John Madden
again here we go all right no office of
color bishops and I can't come to those
things in the middle game it's a matter
with me this is one minute we're going
with the same variation huh no I say
that it's no good John Madden I say it's
just not good going for the same line
yeah let me have that same thing
okay where where are we gonna very where
are we gonna marry
okay let's see variation okay
don't let your pawns fall this time no
Bishop f5 allowed geez went into pac-man
Mountain King stay on light squares
please careful King go here I might
throw a check in there
careful King there we go we got safety
and stuff safety and stuff I'll give you
one check not afraid of that go ahead
give me a careful bishop now we got this
we got this
this is a valuable pond
I got this one John Madden your
never be able to give check I'll stay
behind tantum taunting tactic now how
you give in check back determine okay I
made that I need
I made the proper adjustments I I get to
go back into that line
I'm upon up
I just I can't have those pawns falling
to that bishop
Bishop f5 is what I needed to negate my
CC pons
sir
I'll give them up on and play this right
all right we're going to quiet in the
beginning here
they they try to take twice that's a
problem and they're actually it's a big
problem right now isn't it
can I insert this check I think this is
worthwhile you know I got a second check
I'm one check away
let's go here and material I'm just down
a minor piece now not you can't avoid to
tricky nights no why
now let's just think again just keep
thinking
there here we take here next that's the
way you got to go here
let me go there
let's try this
constantly have to go to different
square nope that's third and final back
to chairman 4838 art and the only loss
was against me
I think we're getting paired up now
please give me white seven minutes to go
okay I got way yes no guarantees but
yeah
oh yeah we got the white pieces let's
ask him a question right now
let's try this cavemen keep the keep the
rook around has the Queen a question
yeah good point good point I'm gonna say
it's okay you're gonna take here you're
crazy you're absolutely crazy no way how
are you getting that third and final
check no way
one check he's angling for right now
Canton you have that can't let you Rick
attic
active I have to negate the rooks no
rook activity no soup for you or is the
activity
I could give two checks I only need one
more check
one check two check now this is how you
do it here so I have this at the end now
that's not quite working yeah it is
clean here here and then I give check
check and then check on this square
to check and now I can't let you castle
let the pieces get active even on the
clock I'm on the rook and I'm on this my
Queens ready to go into pac-man mode
three checks right around the corner
they resigned it's closed
it's definitely closed if I let one of
their pieces get active the rook and in
particular the bishop on his own is
difficult or easy to offset
but the rook the rook goes on a rampage
alright let's control the Knights maybe
this guy'll move and I get to take a
knight with Chuck
let's go here
this room I played this wrong maybe it's
let's
let's go here hmm oh yeah let's think
let's do some more thinking that's all
oh oh that nights dangerous no I don't
want to open up a file I'm ready to sack
oh now I'm giving them a check with this
move I got a check don't hurt me
yes I'm winning
hangout the three checks mmm being
sneaky I was an imp remove motor 5641 40
less than for this term it flies by 76
in here nice turnout for a variant
created John Madden again John Madden is
in second and has fire okay we gotta get
this one this time I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna take that pawn what's what's that
what's the trick with this
oh why not right we'll learn something
not sure why I'm gone there oh okay I
don't have to worry about that
I don't know bring the Queen out oh
you're like a beginner let's go here
I can't castle I need to be able to
castle oh it's not let me castle I'm
spending so much time can I get that
night out of there
I just want to Castle even if they get
some material need to connect trucks
pointing oh I didn't see that
don't hurt me john madden night is so
dangerous hmm i'm in trouble so much
trouble 17 seconds this game could end
so fast though ya gotta get rid of that
night
they
more checks clean check and then pawn
push have to be careful about eight
seconds
I was a chicken
you
whole time burners okay oh man
last one most likely for the tournament
I'll forget what I have to do here let's
try this all right right I forgot about
that one
good point good point man yeah hopefully
I have something magical I don't have
anything magical yeah I'm just down a
rook for what exactly nothing and I'm
not gonna be able to Castle yeah this is
a problem queenside castle and
everything's cool
I could probably safely resign here but
of course I won't
[Laughter]
uncle rook takes pawn is probably
wonderful yeah I'll let him play that
one out nothing wrong to check just for
fun yeah this one's gone I'll let him
play it out bishop check Queen check
ripp check
there's two and there's three yeah nice
I am forgetting that I can't do this
variation is this already lost after
that move close to it now you can't
necessarily trust this but it's
definitely tricky the sacrifice here
Knight takes pawn what's the variation a
Queen h4 or Queen h4 and then there's
something not Queen f6 Queen f6 is
losing Queen h4 is something maybe okay
noted learn something there at the end
okay
that's the final tally that last one
didn't come for the tournament sixty
forty eight forty eight pots her
national took second sixty forty eight
forty eight forty six forty two very
nice crew some tough cookies in there
seventy seventy now let's see all the
pages two three four five six seven and
that's gonna do it
I already
276 of you
good games on as a nice turnout
you